how we think about the the interface
between humans and machines I think is
something that I know Joyce thought a
lot about this is where the idea of
extended intelligence makes a lot of
sense
it also is probably the better way of
thinking about it for our economy and
jobs because people worry that well are
we going to get into a situation where I
mean she's just doing everything and one
of the promising aspects of AI is it
turns out that for example even in
playing chess a computer with a human
oftentimes can do better do better than
just the computer well think about that
application broadly to a lot of
disciplines what we want to be able to
do is develop systems that are open
enough transparent enough that human
judgment human imagination creativity
are still intruding are still active but
a lot of the routine stuff is happening
day to day and in some ways that's just
analogous to you know how will we use
calculators right it's a it's an
extension of our intelligence but it's a
simple enough one that it doesn't feel
as threatening as it does partly because
we understand exactly what's going on
and with a lot of these systems you
start losing track of what are they
doing and I know that's a problem you've
been thinking about a lot for us to be
successful in these areas we really have
to think through the economic
implications because most people aren't
spending a lot of time right now
worrying about singularity they are
worrying about
my job going to be replaced by a machine
and you know I tend to be on the
optimistic side that historically we've
absorbed new technologies and people
find that new jobs are created and they
migrate and our standards of living
generally go up I do think that we may
be in a slightly different period now
simply because of the pervasive
applicability of AI and other
technologies where high skill folks do
very well in this in these systems they
can leverage their talents they can
interface with machines to extend their
reach their sales their products their
services low-wage low-skill individuals
become more and more redundant and their
jobs may not be replaced but wages are
suppressed and if we are going to
successfully manage this transition we
are going to have to have a societal
conversation about how do we manage that
how are we training and ensuring the
economy is inclusive you know if in fact
we're producing more than ever but more
and more of it's going to a small group
at the top how do we make sure that
folks have a living income
you know what does it mean in terms of
us supporting things like the arts or
culture or making sure our veterans are
getting cared for you know so the the
social compact has to accommodate these
new technologies and our economic models
have to accommodate them the good news
is we that's not going to happen
overnight you know let's say that's a
twenty thirty year process if we're
making good decisions now then we can
build the runways so that by the time
AI is fully incorporated into our
economic life people welcome it as
opposed to reject it but we can't assume
that and if we continue on current
trends you're going to continue to see
these populist movements both on the
left and the right that believe that
technology globalization AI the you know
the guys who are off on their own you
know staring at computer screen to
figure this stuff out that all of that
is threatening to the day-to-day lives
of ordinary people and and the values
that they cherish and and and notions of
community and we have to we have to
guard against that that starts with
making sure the economy economic
implications are worked out it's it's
it's actually the non-intuitive which
jobs get displaced because I would bet
that if you had a computer that
understood the medical system and was
very good at Diagnostics then the the
nurse or the farm pharmacist is the
least least liquid it's likely to be and
maybe just the amount of school they
have to go to is just a Community
College instead of medical school my
rule of thumb is if the person looks
like they're doing work that a robot
Renee I could do they're going to be
more likely displaced and there's
actually a very high level jobs maybe
some categories of lawyers or auditors
that might disappear whereas a lot of
the service businesses the arts you know
I think that things that involve things
that computer just aren't well suited
for and and and I think to President
Obama's point I think that we have some
time and
and I don't know what you think about
universal basic income but it I don't
but but as we start to see people
getting displaced there's also this idea
of work provides the structure for
people it provides the purpose and so
can we look at other models like
academia or the arts where people have
purpose or people who will take care of
kids at home and can we somehow because
we don't calculate mom's into GDP that's
crazy right so so I think one of the
problems is there's this general notion
sort of on Wall Street how can it be so
smarter than any money right and and and
and now going into academia I realized a
lot of smart people without money and so
so so I think that also this ties into
the values of society because as we
start to see other work that may have
actually viable work it just isn't as
viewed as working well you're exactly
right
and that's what I mean by redesigning
the social compact now whether a
universal income is the right model is
there going to be accepted by a broad
base of people you know that that's a
debate that we'll be having over the
next 10 years next 20 years and you're
also right that the jobs that are going
to be displaced by AI are not just low
skilled service jobs they might be high
skilled jobs but ones that are
repeatable and computers can do what is
indisputable though is that as AI gets
further incorporated and the society
potentially gets wealthier that the link
between production and distribution how
much you work and how much you make gets
further and further attenuated because
the computers are doing a lot of work
and as a consequence we then have to
make some tougher decisions where are we
already had this problem it's just it's
been so it's not as hyper-charged as
it's going to be we underpaid teachers
despite the fact that that's a really
hard job that's really hard for a
computer
to do well to replace a really good
teacher but we don't value teachers
because it used to be primarily women's
work or because you know it they're a
whole host of reasons why we don't for
us to re-examine what we value what we
collectively are willing to pay for
whether it's teachers nurses caregivers
moms dads who stay at home artists all
the things that are incredibly valuable
to us but right now don't rank high on
the totem pole that's a conversation
that we need to begin to have and enjoys
identified I think they but the ways in
which this could be solved but it's
going to require I think a new way of
thinking and and that's not going to
happen right away
[Music]